remember how great high school was full
of funny people good times maybe a few
parties
you learn some important things about
yourself you're incredibly immature and
you know next to nothing you insist
you're always right no matter what and
refuse to listen to anybody else's
opinion
in reality you're an idiot
it's not the wonder years it's the
blunder years you wear obnoxious
clothing even though it looks terrible
but you can't see it at the time
you do strange things with your hair i
sure did
and you end up with friends
like these troublemakers
bueller
bueller
bueller
but when you grow up and become an adult
you look back on those days and laugh at
how foolish you were your clothes your
hair your friends you realize you were
completely wrong about everything
that's what the democratic party is
going through right now for the last few
years they've acted like children
pushing asinine policies that have hurt
the american people
pretending like they know best when
their foolishness was completely obvious
they supported riots and worshipped
wokeness
the squad was the democrat party's hood
ornament
but now it looks like the adults in the
party are recognizing their mistakes
and when i say adults i really mean
pollsters
according to a report from politico
internal polling by house democrats
showed them what we've been saying all
along they're unlikable and out of touch
with the report highlighting the fact
that some battleground voters think the
party is preachy judgmental and focused
on culture wars
who could have guessed that the average
american doesn't want to see their
representative auditioning to be a
socialite on a red carpet or that voters
didn't want to be judged for backing the
blue
during a crime wave
but don't worry the democrats have an
answer for that too
the politico piece goes on to say that
when faced with a defund the police
attack for instance the presenters
encouraged democrats to reiterate their
support for police
and on immigration they said democrats
should deny support for open borders or
amnesty
and talk about their efforts to keep the
borders safe
democrats actually need polling to tell
them the obvious the american people
support police and strong borders
so the democrats are being advised to
lie and pretend like that's been their
position all along
we're not stupid
we know they've spent the last two years
slandering police calling them racist
defunding them bailing out their
attackers and making their jobs harder
with these soft on crime da's
just listen to them say it for
themselves
not only do we need to defund but we
need to dismantle and start a new
talking about
the reduction of our nypd budget and
defunding a six billion dollar nypd
budget oh yes i support the defund
movement because this is about the
the um
investment
in our communities which have
historically been divested
i am for defunding the police
pro-crime messages like this filled the
streets with blood democrats who are
willing to sacrifice you and your safety
to push their culture wars
and they want to know why the people are
rejecting their message isn't it obvious
people are getting hurt
financially and physically now democrats
are cooking up an alibi before the
midterms even though their fingerprints
are all over america's wounds
rather than focus on real issues like
the chaos at the border or the out of
control inflation
they wanted to make your child feel like
a racist and call you a racist for just
caring about their education
i'm not going to let parents come into
schools and actually take books out make
their own decision i don't think parents
should be telling schools what they
should teach i don't think we would
think we believe that uh educating uh
the youth and next then leaders of the
future leaders of the country on
systemic racism is indoctrination
republicans are using these words like
critical race theory which again is is a
law school curricula that is not even
taught in schools
and their argument is well some teachers
may be exposed to it oh wow so your
child's teacher is not is anti-racist
and is actually fluent in how to
dismantle racism
in in the dynamics of racism in a
classroom
that is something that teachers should
know how to do critical race theory
defund the police this is what the
democrats have stood for
it's a losing message
just ask terry mcauliffe in virginia
democrats were rejected at the ballot
box all across america in 2021
so what's their plan for the midterms
push more lies the politico report goes
on to say this
democrats need to demonstrate they fully
understand and care about stressors in
people's lives and focus on the issues
without stoking divisive cultural
debates
got it
so democrats need to ignore all their
failures on crime covet inflation and
immigration and do a better job
pretending like they actually care about
something
we know they only care about one thing
actually and it's this
today democracy faces a new threat the
january 6 attack on the us capital was
one of the darkest days in the history
of our country in the aftermath of the
january 6 violent insurrection an attack
on the citadel of our democracy when an
angry violent mob staged in insurrection
on january 6 and desecrated our capital
the temple of our democracy it was not
just an attack on the building
it was an attack on our republic itself
democrats know more about january 6 than
they know about the price of gas
ask them how many people stormed the
capital that day and they'll tell you
but ask them how many illegal aliens
cross the border
they don't know
they know more about that date january
6th than america's murder rate
so this new message they push about
compassion and how they support this and
that this isn't because they've done
some soul-searching this isn't them
reckoning with their dangerous policies
it's just a pre-packaged focus group
tested message that they're using to
hide their radical agenda
just until after the election then they
turn back into karl marx
democrats treat voters like children but
they're the sneaky ones we can't take
our eyes off them for a second or
they'll get us all in trouble
the democrats are playing dress-up
because they know they're about to be
punished for who they really are
even voters in san francisco have had
enough of the woke bs
which is a pretty encouraging sign for
us if they can't win with a home field
advantage like that how can they expect
to take
people down in battleground states but
they have nobody to blame but themselves
children across the city were trapped in
their homes during the pandemic as
classroom doors remain shuttered thanks
to the stupid school board
rather than try to mitigate the
exploding adolescent mental health
crisis
the board decided this was a great time
to rename some schools
they attacked schools named for george
washington and abe lincoln
half of the faces on mount rushmore
and arguably america's two greatest
presidents
while their students were glued to a
computer screen
instead of learning in class
well now the chickens have come home to
roost last night
the overwhelmingly liberal city of san
francisco voted to recall three board
members including the board's president
and vice president
parents and voters there sent a clear
message to those in power
we will not stay quiet as you put
progressive politics ahead of our
children
there's been a change in the in the
equilibrium in the landscape of
who's being heard who's at the table
this has shown that parents can't be
ignored any longer we're really
gratified that we could channel that
anger and frustration to something that
is hopefully going to you know lead to a
positive outcome so for the school
district there are so many people who
are upset at the board because
they are not really listening
the people of san francisco have spoken
up and now it's time for the rest of
america the midterms will be here sooner
than you think we need you to stand up
and make sure your voice is heard get
involved in your local race volunteer do
a phone back some canvassing whatever it
takes
because like the saying goes
you can't fix stupid you could only beat
it hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else